sur mes refuge détruits sur mes phares
écroulé sur les murs de mon ennui
j'écris ton nom sur l'absence son désir
sur la solitude nu sur les marches de la
mort j'écris ton nom sur la santé revenu
sur le risque disparu sur l'espoir s'en
souvenir j'écris ton nom et par le
pouvoir d'un mot je recommence ma vie je
suis né pour te connais tu pour te
nommer liberté paul eluard 1942
génériques
[Musique]
merci à vous salut salut à tous je suis
en règle je peux le faire cette émission
s'adresse comme chaque semaine aux
personnes détenues au personnel
pénitentiaire à tous ceux qui sont en
prison mais également à tous ceux qui
sont dehors enfin qu'ils aimeraient bien
l'être à tous ceux qui sont confinés
dans leur maison ou leur appartement
on pense à vous dans les murs
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui au sommaire passi et
son maton qui guette notre fils qui est
sa bibliothèque du sport de la cuisine
pour occuper une rotative une juge
d'application des peines lui aussi et
des heures dès qu'ils se souviennent
est-ce qu'ils sont durs vos souvenirs de
prison absolument mais c'est encore plus
dur de penser combien de gens y sont
toujours sans qu'on leur donne du sens
tu me vois pas c'est quand même fou nous
sommes dans le jardin des tuileries
devant louvre il n'y a que des statues
de femmes et jeudi c'est quand même fou
parce que figurez vous qu aujourd'hui
nous allons à la prison de rennes et que
la prison dure elle est la seule prison
pour femmes exclusivement pour femmes de
france voilà pourquoi les femmes vont en
prison madame on se posait déjà la
question en 1960
[Musique]
les détenus les femmes qui viennent en
prison sont en général condamné et pour
soi pour avoir tué leur mari soit pour
avoir effectué des mauvais traitements
sur leurs propres enfants soit pour
avoir commis des infanticides beaucoup
plus rarement pour avoir commis des vols
qualifiés incroyable archives de 60
alors on retrouve 2020 avec la personne
qui dirige la prison de rennes
bonjour de remix ou c'est bonjour merci
d'être avec nous
[Applaudissements]
on vient de voir quelques images de la
prison de rennes c'est une prison de
longues peines
on vient quand on a des peines de plus
de 15 ans c'est aussi une prison qui est
en centre ville
est-ce que la promenade est resté comme
on vient de la voir oui alors c'est pas
un lieu de promenade un lieu de
circulation donc c'est un établissements
pour peine donc et avec une circulation
dit que porte ouverte
et oui c'est certain c'est un bel
environnement professionnel un bel outil
de travail et je crois qu'elle est plus
sont aussi sensibles à ce lieu à ce
cloître à ce jardin à ces magnifiques et
n'empêche pas du tout la sécurité
alors quand même en 2003 a été ouvert
donc il ya 17 ans ce qu'on appelle les
unités de vie familiale ça c'est
évidemment typique de votre prison est
ce que c'est juste pendu pendant
l'épidémie
oui elles sont suspendues au même titre
que les parloirs
c'est ainsi pilote rennes donc vous avez
raison de dire que depuis 2003 ces
unités de vie familiale sont ouvertes
oui c'est aussi pour l'intérêt d'essayer
de trouver des billets aujourd'hui en
détention et d'essayer de trouver en
tout cas des activités ou des
initiatives incluent alternative pour
rompre cet isolement dans l' isolement
est ce qu'il ya des idées qui ont été
proposées qui vous plaisent alors il ya
plein d'idées on va avoir une cantine
exceptionnel de ce qui n'est pas futile
mais ce qui permet d'améliorer
l'ordinaire et de s'occuper de soi de
prendre soin de soi de la cantine avec
des produits poté et des teintures pour
cheveux favola des choses qu'on peut
essayer qui sont peut-être féminine mais
en tout cas qui permettent aussi de se
projeter dans dans les parois requis et
qui arriveront et de pouvoir maintenir
enclin à bonnac et que cette image de
soi et prendre soin de soi profiter
aussi que ce temps-là différemment
croyez moi que dedans comme dehors on
sait qu combien la teinture pour les
cheveux compte rien coiffure dans la
prison de rennes évidemment il est fermé
et oui il est fermé il est fermé comme
toi ou d'ailleurs et et on parle est un
tueur pour les cheveux mais j'ai vu
aussi qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes qui
s'essaye au masque de beauté pour que
voilà on essaie aussi de leur apporter
apporter cela c'est anecdotique
peut-être mais je crois que c'est
important aussi qu'elle sente qui a
effectivement les liens avec l'extérieur
mais je vous le disais aussi que la
prison elle est dans la cité et on fait
partie de la société ils font partie de
la société et elles ont aussi les
préoccupations qui peuvent rejoindre les
nôtres on va c'est une femme même en
détention c'est ça vous êtes en train de
dire les oui et c'est bien et c'est bien
et c'est bien ainsi
j'ai le sentiment que les obligations de
cette période vous touche
oui elle touche qu'on rende je crois que
quand on est responsable d'une structure
on est aussi attentif à l'équilibré à l'
équilibre des patients des émotions et
il y en a beaucoup
évidemment dans cette période parmi les
personnels aussi qu'il faut rassurer
donc on a aujourd'hui des masques pour
tous les minutes des personnels qui sont
en contact direct et prolongé avec la
population pénale mais il a fallu aussi
rassuré quand quand ce n'était pas le
cas donc voilà aujourd'hui il ya des dp
aussi qui fabrique des masses est on est
on est très fiers de participer à cet
effort collectif
on a passé des images la semaine
dernière de ces détenus chez vous qui
fabrique des masques c'est très
important de la fête du travail donc là
elles peuvent le relais malgré le malgré
le oui non c'est ça ça a été une
réouverture partielle de de l'atelier de
confection dans lequel elle
confectionnait des uniformes et on a
inventé une opératrice aujourd'hui qui
travaillent
c'était sur la base du volontariat c'est
aussi canton je disais que ça participe
et d'une certaine sérénité de
l'établissement je crois que cette fois
à la fois les opératif opératrice pardon
qui travaillent mais ça rayonne sur
l'ensemble de l'établissement de
participer à cet effort collectif à
l'intérêt général
voilà je crois que elles comprennent
aussi ce que ça veut dire que le civisme
et elles sont elles sont fières on est
assez fiers d'elle aussi parce qu'il a
vu voilà deux nouvelles de belles
réalisations et voilà on participe
à cet effort national puisqu'on n'est
pas la seule de prison qui fabrique des
masques mais voilà on a en tout cas
essayer d'être à la hauteur
les ambitions et j'ai hâte aussi cool et
que tous nos partenaires et toutes les
associations que puisse revenir osciller
au centre pénitentiaire et qu'on
retrouve cette vie et ce bruit c'est le
bruit qui vous manquent merci beaucoup
véronique sanson merci infiniment
d'avoir été avec nous on vous cette
journée est pour la fin du film en le
meilleur bien entendu vous savez que je
suis magicienne à 3 je veux du cheval je
viens de vous faire apparaître
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors qui cette semaine pour lire votre
compte rendu de lecture une personne
étonnante qui en 2008 était avocate elle
va voir son cabinet et leur présente sa
démission évidemment le cabinet pense qu
elle part pour la concurrence alors et
de lui proposer une augmentation
colas laredj tout elle sombra car elle
quitte le prétoire pour la scène la
belle échappe aux attendus qui est m
caroline vigneaux bonjour caroline
vigneaux je suis humoriste est
aujourd'hui pour lire pour s'en sortir
je vais vous lire la fiche de lecture
d'un livre que j'aime beaucoup et qui
s'appelle la première gorgée de bière de
philippe delerm un livre que j'ai
beaucoup aimé et apparemment je partage
un peu les mêmes sentiments que la
personne qui a écrit cette puce j'adore
ce recueil
dans ce livre il n'ya pas de préface par
l'introduction pas de remerciements
il n'y a aucun superflu pour gaspiller
notre émotion
on entre directement dans le monde des
plaisirs
ça me fait du bien un monde simple
quotidien comme le mien comme le tien
pendant tout le recueil l'auteur utilise
le on a la place du jeu pour donner
l'impression au lecteur que les plaisirs
va appartenir à tout le monde que chacun
d'entre nous peut trouver des petits
plaisirs dans sa vie chaque jour de
notre vie compte même dans la prison
même si nous avons été privés de notre
liberté fusil qu il y a aussi des
plaisirs minuscules pour moi c'est
chaque mardi matin à 8h30 quand je vois
françois et que nous discutons de
lecture ou alors à l'heure des repas
quand j'aperçois que le dessert du jour
est une religieuse au café ou un
paris-brest
j'ai appelé ce livre la bible des
plaisirs minuscules je vais le poser à
côté de mon lit je vais le lire de temps
en temps car ce livre donne du bien dans
le coeur et la paix à l'intérieur
chacun de nos sentiments et singulier il
faut d'abord utiliser nos yeux pour
regarder puis nos coeurs
sentir et on va la trouver notre quelle
belle vie j'ai alors voilà je suis
totalement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit donc je vous conseille si
vous avez le temps si vous l envie de
lire ce livre et il va vous rappeler
qu'effectivement on peut trouver des
bonnes heures dans des toutes petites
choses et que parfois on n'y aurais pas
pensé et qu'il faut juste s'arrêter et
prendre le temps de se rendre compte que
on est en train de vivre quelque chose
d'agréable
voilà je vous conseille donc très
fortement cette lecture et je vous
embrasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais kia la grande voix de la semaine
qui prend la parole pour vous parler de
vous et donc de nous qui nous
questionnent pour situe m'asseoir sur le
banc je dis bonjour france à sion
bonjour françois sureau merci d'être
avec nous bonjour comment se passent les
confinements pour vous eh bien ça me
donne l'occasion de de travail et
d'écrire un livre auquel je je je
pensais depuis très longtemps je suis
rappelé in her que je n'avais pas eu le
temps de commencer à écrire et vous
savez qu'apollinaire est mort de la
grippe espagnole en le 9 novembre 1918
et donc d'une certaine manière je me
trouve plongé dans une atmosphère qui
n'est pas sans rapport avec l'atmosphère
connaît aujourd'hui voilà c'est une
drôle de manière de s'évader pour parler
d'apollinaire kate est à présent à la
santé entre autres
magnifique extrait d'alcool là bas on
l'avait cité la première émission
absolue en arrivant dans ma cellule
il m'a fallu me mettre nue et une voix
sinistre ulule guillaume que tu devenu
françois silvant vous êtes avocat écrire
un vous avez écrit ce tract sans la
liberté c'est un tract un ses parents
qu'il dit c'est écrit sur la couverture
qui sera d'ailleurs à la disposition des
détenus de la prison de rennes dans la
semaine vous y expliquait que si je vous
comprends bien même et de la liberté
c'est la peur c'est exactement ça est
l'ennemi de la liberté c'est la peur et
c'est aussi le fait de vouloir mettre
absolument aller car ce qui nous dérange
les sociétés modernes ont une difficulté
avec la mort ils ont aussi des
difficultés avec le mal le mal doit être
retranché deux le mal doit être mis
derrière des murs il doit être mis loin
il doit être expulsé vers l'extérieur et
ses sept tentatives d'expulser le mal
vers l'extérieur de fer que le mal ne
soit plus jamais considéré comme une
partie de nous-mêmes des serions purges
c'est quand même assez étrange qui
justifie à la fois la forme moderne de
la prison est aussi un certain nombre de
dispositifs répressifs d'un âtre à payer
est ce qu'on pense à ces aux personnes
détenues ac ou suffisamment bien la
prison vous savez je pense je voudrais
pas paraître naïf mais je pense que la
liberté dans le sens le plus intime et
le plus personnel
et vraiment ce qui nous constitue je
crois que c'est vraiment une partie de
notre être props et pas simplement ce
qui est nécessaire à l'énergie de la vie
sociale c'est aussi quelque chose de
profondément intime à quoi nous ne
pouvons pas renoncer et à quoi nous ne
pouvons pas demander aux autres de
renoncer vous savez pendant longtemps
pendant longtemps dans les systèmes
judiciaires civilisé la tentative
d'évasion n'était pas susceptible d'être
réprimée parce que la doctrine considéré
qu'il était normal quoi que ce soit
qu'un homme ait fait qu'il souhaite
retrouver sa liberté
ça n'a changé qu'après avec avec la loi
perben en france et vous avez des tas de
décisions de cour suprême étrangères
brésiliennes mexicaines par exemple qui
considère qu' on ne peut pas réprimer le
le le désir de liberté
est-ce que vous avez réfléchi vous une
autre manière que la privation de
liberté pour payer ses erreurs je pense
que la liberté ont ce qu'elle est
vraiment ceux qui constituent l'homme
il est assez peu civilisés dont privé un
homme pour des raisons autres que
l'atteinte direct aux personnes parce
que quand on le fait en fait on met en
balance deux quantité incommensurable
on le prix de la liberté est un bien un
fini au lieu simplement par exemple de
l'obliger à rembourser ou est ce que je
veux dire je je je je sais par est en
réalité d'abord en matière d'erreurs les
atteintes à la vie les atteintes aux
personnes et les atteintes aux biens les
atteintes aux biens en réalité de
manière presque philosophique me
paraissent ne pas devoir faire l'objet
de la privation de liberté vous savez
que c'est assez récent 1 le moyen-âge
par exemple qu'on décrit comme quelque
chose d'assez sombrer d'abominables le
moyen-âge qui était très cruel pour
certains crimes le pari si la laisse
majesté séoul blasphème le moyen-âge par
ailleurs ne n'aurais pas du tout conçu
n'aurait pas du tout trouvé acceptable
le fait qu'on prive de liberté quelqu'un
pour de simples raisons d'atteintes aux
biens est en fait les gens faisait
amende
rabelais ensuite il était condamné à
rembourser c'était quelquefois très
pénibles parce qu'ils devaient se mettre
au service de ceux qu'ils avaient volé
si je puis dire pour rembourser mais
mais c'était mais c'était quelque chose
à certains égards de de plus civilisée
que notre de notre système actuel de la
république bourgeoise si je puis dire
est ce que vous auriez un conseil de
lecture pour ça qu'ils s'endettent nu et
pour les personnels pénitentiaires
je donnerai deux conseils d'abord si
j'étais détenu il me semble que je
voudrais m'évader de manière absolue
c'est à dire lire les aventures d'arsène
lupin par exemple les trois
mousquetaires foyer quelque chose avec
des cavalcades avec des avec le fait de
passer sur les routes avec le fait de
s'en aller ailleurs au loin ou bien
quelque chose qui d'une certaine manière
puisse me permettre de méditer
l'expérience de l' isolement et là
dessus il ya un livre qui m'accompagne
depuis mon enfance que je trouve
absolument phénoménale que je relis
chaque année et qui à mon avis peut être
lu en prison c'est robinson c'est
robinson crusoé de daniel defoe ckoi
robinson crusoé et bien c'est quelqu'un
qui en fait subi l'incarcération dans
une il commence par se demander si c'est
de sa faute commence par se demander ce
que la providence a bien voulu faire de
lui en l'enfermant sur cette île et qui
ensuite essaye de se recréer une vie
matérielle si réduite soit elle est une
vie intérieure à partir de l'expérience
de l' isolement et et pour ça je trouve
que robinson crusoé est un livre
absolument indépassable
les détenus de la prison de reims vont
pouvoir lire votre texte sans la liberté
est ce que ça vous touche france
assurant évidemment elle me évidemment
il me touche vous savez je crois que la
raison profonde qu'un homme peut avoir
de devenir avocat métier j'ai découvert
sur le tard et presque par hasard c'est
que l'accusation est toujours injuste et
que bien sûr il faut payer sa dette à
l'égard de la société mais que la
détention entraîne dans une épreuve
existentielle qui est presque sans
rapport avec la faute commise et c'est
un discours qui est très difficilement
audible peu les gens ne sont pas prêts à
entendre mais mais tout ce qui peut être
fait pour préparer les détenus quand ils
sortent
on au fait d'être comme nous des
citoyens avides de liberté parce qu'ils
auront su ce que c'est que d'en être
privée est quelque chose qui me paraît
fondamental est qui et qui m'émeut
profondément
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous et bonne fin de confinement si on
voit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un deux trois quatre boules de cuir sur
quatre pieds de guerre bombarde le
plexus boxe boxe ça c'est la chanson de
nougaro nous allons rester en forme
aujourd'hui pour vous aider comme
d'habitude nous avons un très grand
champion avec nous s'agit d'un vice
champion olympique champion du monde
2010 est des poids légers et capitaine
de l'équipe de france porte stoxx
sofiane oumiha jeu par alan droite
tendue à tous c'est sofiane oumiha du
chanteur olympique et champion du monde
de boxe anglaise
j'espère que ça se passe comme non donc
je vous donner quelques exo à faire en
ces temps difficiles
donc on va partir sur des exo simple
basique on l'attendait avec les gens et
les abdos
premières exo encore sur des pans 15
points on part sur 15 points bras
écartés
[Musique]
on est là on touche
encore 10 à 15 secondes de l'été passé
en force on consomme on sort de ma
dépendance et jusqu'à secondes de
récupération et enfin sur deux d'or
physique et on va sur un deuxième tour a
fini le tour pas sur les autres
déjà on va sur trente secondes jambe
gauche qui ont commencé quand on donne
nos scores gagné droit
donner et on enchaîne sur un deuxième
tour entre les autres en secondes noces
on part sur une idée récupération enfin
second tour j'espère que ça va vous
plaire donc fort ça vous pousse à nous
et j'espère y avait tout un ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
figurez-vous qu'en de cette émission a
commencé il ya un mois il a été un des
tout premiers députés à nous appeler et
à nous dire qu'ils souhaitaient
participer
bonjour aurélien pradié bonjour ou sam
nous là ça n'est pas chez vous non je
suis à la mairie où je suis élue nos
petits villages labastide murat
donc j'aime terme mais journée entre mon
domicile de la mairie pour gérer aussi
quelques quelques affaires courantes et
urgentes avec l'équipe municipale
là je faisais la salle des délibérations
voilà qui explique marianne derrière oui
en tant que député vous participer aux
délibérations réflexion autour de la
prison et du monde carcéral
oui je suis membre de la commission des
lois dont c'est un sujet qui revient
souvent dans nos travaux moi j'ai pas
une sensibilité particulière spéciale à
cette question là je suis rentré dans
dans le milieu carcéral tôt j'ai
commencé à traiter cette question là
avec le personnage de simone veil
il ya déjà quelques années c'est un
personnage qui qui m a poussé à faire de
la politique quand j'étais tout jeune
gamin et qui ont laissé des prisons et
ça m'avait beaucoup frappé parce que
personne n'ignore évidemment le rapport
que simone veil a pu avoir avec
l'incarcération et que cette femme-là a
choisi dans son premier engagement
professionnel comme magistrate de
traiter de cette question de
l'incarcération et d'améliorer les
conditions d'incarcération
je pense que c'était une belle marque à
la fois d'humanité de ce que sont les
valeurs de la république
quand même aurélien pradié on a le
sentiment que la prison pour les
politiques c'est quand même la dernière
roue du carrosse on ne peut pas faire
des promesses électorales autour de
l'organisation de la pénitentiaire déjà
en 2009 nicolas sarkozy disait que
l'état des prisons
c'était une honte pour la république ça
n'avance pas le politique ne fait pas
avancer à faire vous avez raison de dire
que c'est un sujet qui à paris
secondaire dans les programmes
politiques et pourtant nicolas sarkozy
l'avait dit à l'époque
d'autres l'ont dit par le passé c'est
sûrement pas notre priorité aujourd'hui
et pourtant c'est un sujet stratégique
vous savez même les plus durs à droite
conviennent que si on traite de manière
aussi négligente les femmes et les
hommes qui sont en prison le risque
c'est la récidive
le risque c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est que ces prisons soient
des lieux de contamination notamment du
terrorisme pourri même pour ceux qui
sont les moins altruiste de tous
il ya une raison profonde à 2
voir s'intéresser aux prisons parce que
c'est la réhabilitation dans la société
dont il est question
plutôt que d'avoir des bombes en
puissance qui sort de nos prisons
françaises est donc finalement quand
vous êtes allé en prison
qu'est ce que vous avez vu ce que j'ai
vu ce sont deux choses d'abord des
conditions d'incarcération qui en effet
dans bien des lieux sont absolument
déplorable détestable la prise en charge
la santé mentale qui nous préoccupe
beaucoup
on a plus aujourd'hui de prise en charge
psychiatrique dans les prisons et ça
devienne catastrophique
et puis la détresse de celles et ceux
qui travaillent dans les prisons du
personnel pénitencier notamment qui est
soumis à une pression à une mise en
danger considérable
ces lieux sont des véritables bombes on
le sait on le mesure aujourd'hui parfois
on entasse des prisonniers les uns sur
les autres
enfin tout ça ne peut pas nous laisser
insensible on peut pas ressortir de ces
musiques là sans se dire qu'on a une
haute responsabilité politique qui de
fer qu'on sanctionne celles et ceux qui
ont fauté mais qu'on respecte leur
humanité et alors du coup qu'est ce que
vous proposez
on construit des prisons où est ce qu'on
sait les gens de prison non je pense
qu'il faut construire des prisons la
solution de sortir les gens de prison on
sait bien aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
la meilleure solution
je le dis comme citoyenne comme
responsable politique je pense que
l'acte de privation de liberté est un
acte qui peut fabriquer le déclic
quel droit devrais ton leur accorder le
droit c'est celui d'avoir une nouvelle
chance c'est le droit de l'humanité
qu'on met tous des erreurs parfois plus
graves que d'autres et je crois que la
chance la possibilité de réhabilitation
de l'être humain est au coeur de notre
pacte social
si on ne croit plus en cela on lui coupe
le rien le vrai sujet c'est comment on
laisse une nouvelle chance à une femme
ou un homme de se reconstruire
ça c'est un vrai droit c'est un immense
droit qui aujourd'hui n'existe pas
réellement
et ça c'est le travail des politiques et
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'ils
n'avancent pas beaucoup depuis de
longues années
enfin je ne le fait que ça va changer
est-ce que vous avez un conseil de
lecture à faire pour ceux qui sont
détenus ou les personnels pénitentiaires
oui j'en ai un c'est l'iliade et
l'odyssée qui pour moi est un
livre majeur s'il y en a deux à lire
c'est notamment celui ci ça fait partie
du berceau littéraire de l'humanité j'ai
grandi avec il y a des l'odyssée j'ai
découvert assez tard en fait que je
relis au moins au moins tous les anges
invite toutes celles et ceux qui ne le
connaissent pas à lire cet ouvrage
majeur qui parle d' aventure qui parle
d' honneur qui parle de conquête qui
parle aussi d'amour de sa patrie de son
foyer qui parlent de liberté qui parle
de voyage qui parle de dieu qui parle de
leicester enfin bref qui parle de
l'humanité merci beaucoup aurélien
pradié merci à vous merci à vous et
bonne fin de confinement vous aussi
portez vous bien
merci beaucoup on va rester à
l'assemblée avec un autre conseil de
lecture est donc un autre député
ugo bernalicis que je vais retrouver
maintenant ugo bernalicis qui sort de
prison
non pas que enfin bonjour bonjour ugo
bernalicis bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes vous êtes chez vous la
wii je suis chez moi je suis revenu de
prison
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes chez vous mais vous sortez de
prison enfin c'est à dire que vous êtes
allé visiter tout à l'heure la prison de
l'île sauf que d'un pourquoi et
qu'alliez vous y voir je voulais voir ce
n'est pas la première fois que je vais
visiter une prison ça va être la 16e
fois la de mémoire depuis le début du
mandat
je voulais voir justement comment
s'organiser la prison et la détention
dans cette période de pandémie ducobu de
comment ça se passe on nous dit qu'il ya
des masses pour le personnel
pénitentiaire et ce qu'ils en ont
vraiment on nous dit que en est on a
vidé les prisons et qui a beaucoup de
condamnés qui ont pu sortir est ce que
c'est vrai comment ensuite on s'est
organisé pour pour mettre des gens
confinement puisqu'il y en a qui quand
ils arrivent on me dit qu'on les garde
14 jours à l'encellulement individuel
bon voilà comme comment ça fonctionne il
ya la gratuité du téléphone mais il n'y
a pas des téléphones dans les cellules
donc comment commence à s'organiser ce
qu'il ya des files d'attentes pour aller
voir le téléphone
comment ça se passe les soins en
détention enfin voilà toutes les
questions d'ordinaire vu sous le prisme
de cette de cette pandémie
il se posait beaucoup de questions un
peu comme tout le monde sur le 11 mai
cette fameuse date de de déconfinement
est ce que je pourrais avoir des
parloirs est-ce que je vais pouvoir
c'était drôle parce que beaucoup m'ont
dit
heureusement qu'on a la télé pour se
tenir informés de ce qui se passe dehors
et puis elle aussi cause aussi vite dit
au début on l'a regardé beaucoup mais
maintenant j'ai arrêté parce que ça me
rend ça nous fait plus peur qu'autre
chose d'un coup qu'il faut faire
attention au côté hawks iogen aussi de
tout ce qui peut se raconter sur les
chaînes d'info et parce que c'est date
du 11 mai elles pourraient avoir une
importance aussi déterminante pour les
personnes détenues parce que figurez
vous que depuis le début du confinement
enfin vous le savez parfaitement il ya
plus de parloirs et donc pour beaucoup
le 11 mai c'est de se dire ah peut-être
peut-être que le 11 mai je vais pouvoir
parler de vive voix à mes proches à mes
amis à ma famille et ça c'est important
est ce qu'il ya des cas de covin oui il
y a des cas confirmés de covin j'ai
d'ailleurs pu m'entretenir avec avec un
détenu testés positifs qui était enfin
deux enfin de câbles 14/n dans une
cellule à l'isolément
donc oui il y en a il ya des cas
suspects et aussi et on voit bien là que
bon ben ok il ya des protocoles qui sont
mis en place ils sont mis dans un
quartier un peu à part les surveillants
qui sont là ils ont des masques ffp2
alors que les autres ont que des masques
chirurgicaux
il ya quelques mesures qui sont prises
mais vous voyez bien que vu qu'ils
manquent de masques et vu qu'on peut pas
faire des tests pour tout le monde
bon bah on fait comme on peut quoi ugo
bernalicis est ce que je peux vous
demander un conseil de lecture pour les
personnes détenues et les personnels
pénitentiaires
oui puis ce qui marque tout de suite
qu'ils vont regarder l'émission alors
oui c'est un livre de maxime reina i qui
s'appelle là où est l'argent qui est
qu'il ya un livre donc maxime je les
rencontre est par ailleurs de visu qui a
été un formateur indique de la dgse dans
les paradis fiscaux
il travaillait lui-même dans un paradis
fiscal et ça vient nous rappeler alors
il raconte ça ils racontent un peu son
expérience et sa vie que vous savez dans
ces périodes où on cherche des milliards
pour fabriquer des masques pour
compenser les entreprises qui sont en
difficulté pour aider les petits et les
petits entrepreneurs pour aider les
indépendants etc
eh ben il ya des milliards qui dorment
on le sait dans les paradis fiscaux et
l'oeil lille il raconte avec ses mots
avec son histoire nous donne quelques
détails croustillants
c'est interroge quand même sur notre
société et sur le monde d'après qu'il
faudra construire
merci beaucoup et gouverne avis bonne
fin de journée en fin de journée
[Applaudissements]
quand anges on chante
ah non pas ce que c'est il ya des
chansons mais nous le live de la semaine
c'est pas le monsieur qui chante en
italien au fond de la scène pas du tout
nous c'est un truc qui a marqué le
mythique le maton big est offert en
passant par passi et tu es tu continue
de reculer tu vas finir le live de la
semaine j'aurai tout s'est passé
j'espère que ça va et que le courage et
leur en pleine période de confinement
donc mon petit conseil lecture un petit
livre très intéressant et en même temps
parce que j'aime la personne qu'il écrit
et le couple donc c'est de venir lui
shell obama donc oui oui barack obama et
michelle obama parcourent incroyable et
donc dans ce livre elle donne sa vision
et raconte sa vie par de la base de sa
vie et de la vision de la deuxième dame
de la femme derrière mais aussi la
personne qui entreprend aussi avec bach
il y a encore tant de choses que
j'ignore au sujet de l'amérique
de l'avis de ce que l'avenir leur
réserve mais je sais qui je suis on perd
frazer appris à travailler dur à rire
souvent et à tenir ma parole
ma mère marianne à penser par moi même
et à faire entendre ma voix
tous les deux ensemble dans notre petit
appartement du quartier de south side de
chicago
ils m'ont aidé à saisir ce qui faisait
la valeur de notre histoire de mon
histoire et plus largement de l'histoire
de notre pays
même quand elle est loin d'être belle
elle est parfaite même quand la réalité
se rappelle à vous plus que vous ne
l'auriez souhaité votre histoire vous
appartient elle vous appartiendra
toujours à vous de vous en emparer
c'est lors du live donc une petite
pensée à tous ceux qui nous regardent
partout et une petite pensée à tous et
derrière les barreaux bien sûr ce titre
est pour vous les menottes
les notes la machine à taper son nom
prénom naissance nationalité poches
vides et ensuite lacets ceinture enlevé
de l'artifice et l'armistice le pays est
en fait pour moi la fête en garde à vue
dans les cages de la police 9h 11h
parlement et sur le tage fsi pas d'en
faire des galères à pois ce les
empreintes et plainte et ce tribunal ma
famille et mes proches un soutien
principal par
on peint pour les flics s'éclate rôle à
fond on avocat et claire juge persévère
et les vingt ans matricule 49 2 sans 3
contres en cellule des 128 la porte
claque monture bas mon cousin 49 204 peu
parlent de date
un math enchaîne sur l'e business et
rate de troubler dans ma tête et de
maintenance de kate encore étant fermés
seulement dames peuvent en dire par aux
portes bloquées avis est bloqué derrière
l'oeil et je rêve de m'évader le trouble
et dans ma tête et le matin tu te guette
donc une petite pensée à tous ceux qui
sont derrière les barreaux à tous ceux
qui sont confinées à la maison
courage courage courage courage courage
c'est pas si
[Applaudissements]
c'était l'enfer que le groupe que nous
allons retrouver maintenant je fais vite
parce que j'ai par contre suivent
alain finkielkraut doigt sur certains
grands penseurs un grand penseur grand
philosophe quelqu'un qui s'agace qui ces
rites qui s'énerve vie quoi en tout cas
quand on lui a demandé de nous ouvrir sa
porte
il n'a pas hésité et il nous emmène dans
sa bibliothèque
avec la pandémie de coronavirus nous
vivants traversons une crise sans
précédent
cet événement accapare toute notre
attention
nous sommes donc inquiets angoisse est
obsédé on peut faire le joie le choix de
l'évasion par la lecture on peut aussi
chercher un écho de ce qui nous arrive
dans les lire
j'appartiens à la catégorie de ceux qui
attendent la littérature un éclairage
plutôt qu'une distraction
j'ai donc d'abord penser à la peste de
camus
je me suis dit que personne n'avait
besoin de moi pour ce livre alors à ceux
qui sont qui à leur confinement
habituels ajoute le terrible
désagréments une suspension du droit de
visite
je voudrais conseiller un roman que sans
doute ils ne connaissent pas
c'est némésis de philippe brandt son
bernier louise publié en 2010 philip
roth en revanche américains imaginent
une épidémie de poliomyélite à new york
sa ville natale pendant la guerre dans
les années 40
son héros s'appelle bucky cantor c'est
un professeur de gymnastique
il s'occupe des enfants et des
adolescents
terrorisée par cette épidémie il essaye
de les rassurer
il leur apprend ce qu'on n'appelait pas
encore les gestes barrière est amoureux
d'une jeune fille marcia avec laquelle
il se fit en syrie va l'avoir
il s'interrompt ne peut pas en quelques
jours pour aller voir dans un camp de
vacances
or il ne le sait pas mais c'est sans
doute le porteurs asymptomatiques de la
maladie des enfants dans ce camp de
vacances tombent malades
il revient d'autres tombent malade et
lui aussi il a la poliomyélite in en
sort durement atteint pas complètement
paralysé mais handicapé il se dit qu'il
est responsable de l'extension de la
maladie puisque l'un des porteurs sans
savoir du virus et il cherche la
rédemption pour cette terrible faute et
il la trouve en renonçant à 7 mars ya 7
mars air qui ne demandent pas mieux que
de se marier avec lui en dépit de son
handicap il dit non il ne le veut pas il
gâche complètement son existence la fin
est vraiment bouleversant la faim
publique et maintenant j'en viens pour
finir au titre nemesis nemesis dans la
mythologie grecque
c'est la puissance vengeresse la
puissance divine qui punit qui a baladé
mesure l'hubris on peut en venir un
autre
notre situation l'hubris pense-t-on et à
juste titre c'est peut-être la démesure
de l'exploitation de la nature et la
nature nous lance un ultimatum dit
nicolas hué mais là c'est une autre des
mesures à laquelle nous devons penser
aussi la démesure de l'explication de
quiconque a besoin que tous fassent ans
il faut que tout est une raison alors
d'abord ces dieux qu'ils pointent du
doigt puis s'est lui même mais il a
besoin
il a besoin de comprendre il a besoin
d'une raison et donc même d'un coup pas
d'un coupable
il convertit comme le dernier les sticks
of la tragédie en culpabilité
ils n'acceptent pas ce que tu avais cet
événement à d'aléatoire de contingents
d'absurde et je trouve que ce roman
donne énormément à penser il faut
évidemment réfléchir à toutes les
raisons qui nous ont mis dans cette
situation mais ne pas oublier la
contingence la surdité
le hasard et j'en viens à un autre livre
qui est le peut-être plus grands romans
de philip roth pastorale américaine
donc voilà je pense que ces deux lire
mérite d'être lu ils sont palpitants et
donne aussi beaucoup à penser nemesis et
pastorale
gédéon la semaine dernière on s'est mal
qui tu es toi et moi c'est pas tout de
suite qu'on va manger du magret de
canard
je peux encore tout à fait au point pour
la survie en milieu sauvage mais il en
reste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
va dans la geste barrière là bas tu vois
la salle à voilà là on peut travailler
correctement pendant quatre émissions il
nous a abreuvés de conseils et ce garçon
sait de quoi il parle quand il parle
prison ou quand il parle cuisine
après la recette de la galette de maïs
ou encore de l'oeuf mollet je pars là je
parle à un petit c'est pas le risotto de
pacte voilà que le chef marc didden sa
dernière recette
la recette du dessert êtes une douceur
chef toi recule par contre puisque
bonjour thierry marx aujourd'hui un plat
à moins de trois euros et avec la liste
cantine à bhl en détention on va
attaquer un pain d'épicés façon pain
perdu
home rôti banane avec de la vanille du
miel du sucre vers joie c'est le sucre
roux si vous n'avez pas de sucre roux on
peut continuer j'ai vu qu'il ya du sucre
roux et du sucre blanc vous pouvez
prendre du sucre blanc n'y a aucun souci
on va voir pour démarrer un petit
caramel faire marquer nos pommes dedans
ensuite nos banane ensuite notre pain d
épices et après celle dressage pomme
gros quartier j'enlève la peau voilà mes
morceaux de pommes c'est prêt mon beurre
et là maintenant on va attaquer le
caramel on voit bien qu'elle est très
très très très chaude donc on va y aller
tout doucement pour faire le caramel jeu
tapissent le fond
voyez le caramel commence à se faire il
brûle pas je suis à peine à deux sur la
plaque
prenez votre temps pour faire le caramel
je me suis offert c'est magique
une petite gousse de vanille que je vais
mettre directement dedans alors ça j'ai
pas pu continuer j'en ai pas trouvé donc
à sucre vanillé trala faire maintenant
je vais ajouter un petit morceau de
beurre petit si vous avez le beurre salé
boîte un caramel beurre salé ce sera le
même principe
voilà et maintenant je vais ajouter les
pommes
et je vais les enrobés au maximum de
dents vraiment vraiment on va bien bien
bien les enrober je change pas la
température de ma plaque pour pas que ça
aille trop vite
de toute façon ça va caramélisées
maintenant on va rajouter un tout petit
peu tout petit peu petit peu de miel et
on laisse cuire tout doucement tout le
chemin tout doucement pendant ce temps
on va préparer la balade
j'aime bien la pause ici et là tout doux
tout doux tout doux pendant ce temps je
vais couper les bordures de mon palais
pis l'excédent de cuisson comme on dit a
commencé à imprégner notepad épices
préparation 15 à 20 minutes sa part est
rapide comme ça mais de bien confie
relais bananes et les pommes à feu doux
pour que le caramel ne brûle pas compté
20 minutes il n'y a pas besoin de 9,1
perdu traditionnement il ya un peu des
faits de lait là mon jus de cuisson des
pommes ça suffit
j'ai mon jus on va venir arroser les
pommes la banane pain perdu par des peas
et là on est à 2 euros
25 bon appétit à filmer film se fait
arrêter là c'est le moment où j'avais
dit qu'ils viennent me chercher
ils arrivent ils sont là j'en ai bien
peur bonjour vous vous promenez pas la
police ne fait plus son métier comprends
pas ce qui est bon jour ça va
super bien on est comme vous on bosse
ils sont pas mal vos bicloo c'est quoi
oui mais là si on discute du confort non
métro tout un journée je vous assure que
vous prendrez si bien sûr non gestes
barrières nadal à la ola la bonne
journée votre journée il oppose aux
[Rires]
quais j'aime le pauliste
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant une femme très importante
qu on est très heureux de recevoir dans
cette émission
bonjour cécile dangles bonjour vous êtes
présidente de l'association nationale
des juges d'application des peines le
juge ou la juge d'application des peines
est celui qui décide de comment
s'applique la peine
c'est exactement ça on travaille à la
faune en milieu ouvert avec des gens qui
sont laissés libres à la sortie du
tribunal
on travaille aussi avec des détenus dans
différents établissements d'ailleurs un
des maisons d'arrêt pour les courtes
peines des centres de détention pour des
peines un petit peu plus longue et des
maisons centrales aussi plus sécuritaire
l'application des peines elle va jusqu'à
savoir si le détenu va être en cellule
ou en dortoir ça va jusque là parce que
la loi nous le demandait il ya un
article du code de procédure pénale qui
nous demande de prendre en compte la
surpopulation carcérale dans nos choix
d'aménagement de peine donc oui on
s'intéresse à ça de toute façon parce
que c'est la loi mais j'ai envie de dire
humainement bien sûr qu'on s'y intéresse
parce qu'on sait bien que entre une
personne qui peut être seul en cellule
accompagné avec des activités et une
personne qui en dortoir ou à 3,4 ou kill
or sur un matelas on sait très bien
qu'on ne peut rien travaillé avec la
personne parce que parce que quand on
est dans un espace de 9 m² à 2 3 4 la
priorité c'est comment slave comme en
vente aux toilettes avec un minimum
d'intimité
comment gères la promiscuité comment on
fait pour quoi se faire en plus
complètement embêté par les autres voilà
la priorité c'est ce quotidien là et
c'est tellement accaparant que tout le
reste autour c'est inaudible
donc nous on peut bien recevoir les gens
veut bien leur dire des choses vous
pouvez alors proposé de travailler sur
un certain nombre de sujets ils sont
accaparés par leur quotidien et c'est
bien normal et donc ce qu'on fait nous
sert absolument à rien vous dites
également que les condamnés qu'ils sont
en prison pour moins d'un an vous ne
leur est également d'aucune utilité
pourquoi oui parce que les gens rentrent
en détention ils sont pris par ce
système là des maisons d'arrêt
surpeuplées
donc ils ont pas accès à des activités
parce que leur peine et dit trop courte
l'accès au premier rendez vous médical
mais des fois ça peut être trois mois et
ensuite c'est très espacées donc on
demande aux gens parfois mais dites donc
fait un travail d'introspection
c'est juste pas possible déjà l'accès
aux soins est compliqué et puis une fois
que d'ailleurs on peut avoir un rendez
vous avec un soignant un psychologue ou
psychiatre quand on revient en cellule
on se retrouve l'appareil dans un
environnement qui permet pas la
réflexion et et la remise en question
donc voila quand on est sur des courtes
peines dans ces établissements surchargé
mais les gens arrivent ils subissent
leur punk comme ils peuvent et au mieux
ils en sortent pareil et au pire ils
sortent dans des situations plus
dégradée s'ils avaient un travail l'ont
perdu si vous avez un logement peut-être
aussi l'ont perdu faut quand même savoir
que 28% des personnes qui sortent des
maisons d'arrêt sortent sans logement
pardon facile dans mais c'est vrai qu'on
fasse un point c'est bien parce que ça
peut surprendre c'est bien la présidente
de l'association des juges d'application
des peines qui me parle là et pas être
dangereuse rebelles putschistes droits
de l'hommistes oui c'est un peu ça
wip qu'il faut que je le dise très
clairement moi j'aime beaucoup
travailler en prison
je crois que c'est la partie de mon
travail qui m'a le plus appris j'ai fait
de très belles rencontres et les gens
engagés en prison il ya des surveillants
qui au quotidien et c'est de donner du
sens à ce qu'ils font il ya des
formateurs
il ya des visiteurs de prison et puis
y'a des détenus aussi qui sont très
intéressants parce qu'ils sont en train
de se battre pour changer leur vie ce
qu'on vit en prison est très intense et
très intéressant moi je crois à l'outil
prison et c'est parce que j'y crois que
au niveau de l'association des juges
d'application des peines
nous sommes en demande de changement
profond cécile dangles s'est tassée par
vous que passent les décisions de
libérations anticipées
on parle de dix mille personnes c'est ça
il ya eu différents processus en fait un
dans les dix mille c'est pas dix mille
personnes qui sortent de prison en fait
ces dix mille personnes
aujourd'hui en moins par rapport à
l'avant crise sanitaire c'est à dire
qu'il ya des gens qui ne sont pas entrés
en prison il ya des procureurs de la
république qui ont fait le choix de
différer des mises à exécution qui ont
fait le choix d'orienter aussi des
procédures des poursuites
autrement qu'avant donc pour en prenant
du temps du temps de peut-être plus de
réflexion d'accompagnement avant ce
qu'on appelle le contrôle judiciaire
preuve que c'est possible d'envisager
des politiques autrement
et puis il ya des gens donc ils sont pas
rentrés en prison qu'il ya des gens qui
en sont sortis avec le travail des juges
d'application des peines ça peut être en
effet ses réductions de peine
exceptionnelle de deux mois qu'ils sont
quand même pas d'une grande générosité
j'ai envie de dire pendant deux mois les
gens sont confinés en prison sans visite
sans parloir s'en sortir sans activité
bon ça me paraît assez normal qu'ils
aient ses réductions de peine
donc ça ça fera sortir un certain nombre
de personnes
il ya aussi la mise en place
d'aménagements de peine spécifique lire
on a déployé plus d'aménagements de
peine que d'habitude pour tenir compte
de cette situation de difficulté moi
j'ai en tête des situations enfin je
veux dire des père de famille qui en
plusieurs enfants leurs femmes étaient
soignante par exemple ben oui il fallait
le sortir cet homme il était en capacité
d'être à l'extérieur on avait déjà
travaillé des choses ensemble fallait
qu'ils sortent pour aller s'occuper de
sa famille et permettre à sa femme
d'aller elle ça veut dire le rail ce
personnel
merci infiniment merci merci beaucoup à
vous j'en profite pour vous lancer un
petit message personnel tant que les
parloirs ne sont pas ouverts et on ne
sait pas quand ça sera sera pas
forcément
le 11 mai date du début de déconfinement
tant que les parloirs ne sont pas
ouverts vous pouvez de nous adresser
tous les messages que vous souhaitez
envoyer aux détenus il suffit de les
adresser à des confinement at lire pour
en sortir point org ou alors vous allez
sur twitter des confiné au pluriel
et si vous êtes détenus vous pouvez nous
écrire ce qui vous arrive en ce moment
ce qui vous passe par la tête un message
que vous avez envie d'envoyer à lcp 106
rue de l'université 75007 paris j'ai
l'impression d'être dans un jeu avec le
truc vous savez est un indice s'inscrire
de vote de votre écran pour là c'est une
adresse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chers tous j'ai des messages personnels
pour vous le premier est signé par
stéphane d'auxilia je vous souhaite
beaucoup de courage pour cette période
je pense très fort à vous tenez le coup
on sortira grandi de cette épreuve un
coucou chaleureux au grand nicolas de la
santé à julio le musicien bolivien de
fleury à fred et à la team melun à yanis
de fresnes à stevenson de bapaume à ianu
et michel de joux-la-ville à fabrice
lamy papillon de vendin le vieil à
jean-philippe de roanne et à tous les
apprenants d'auxilia force à vous merci
stéphane j'espère que le message est
bien passé j'en ai un autre aussi d'un
rappeur s'appelle dos et qu'il est
disque de diamant
voilà ce qu'il a à nous dire salut à
tous salut à toutes
l'autre gros dossier un petit message
pour pour tous les gens derrière les
barreaux dans tout l'est dans toutes les
prises en france et d'ailleurs je
voudrais un gros message de courts
messages de soutien déjà en temps normal
c'est une situation qui n'est pas facile
à vivre donc donc ne serait ce que par
rapport à ça grand courage et en plus de
ça on traverse une crise
une situation qui est vraiment vraiment
vraiment vraiment vraiment très complexe
très compliqué voilà ce fameux
coronavirus se forment le confinement
cette fameuse contamination est clair
donc je sais pas exactement quelles sont
les quelles sont les mesures qui sont
possibles
de prendre prison par rapport à ça pour
vous protéger
vous n'avez pas de masque même si même
si nous aussi donné plan a pas mort
d'homme ans malheureusement mais mais je
pense que lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on est en
prison ça va être encore plus compliqué
à gérer surtout qu à pas mal de deux
maisons d'arrêt qui sont qui sont
surpeuplés donc donc c'est clair que les
gestes barrière ça va être compliqué à
respecter lorsqu'on est entassé dans une
cellule on n'est pas censé être plus que
deux mais bon voilà je sais pas du tout
ce que ce que l'état cru pour pour vous
j'espère en tout cas qu'il a prévu
quelque chose pour vous parce que je
pense que je pense que s'il ya bien un
endroit où ça doit être super super
super facile d'euros de contaminer tout
le monde sait là-bas
forcément vous êtes vous êtes un peu les
uns sur les autres c'est compliqué mais
en tout cas voilà nous la seule chose
qu'on peut faire de notre côté c'est de
penser à vos fortement voilà moi j'ai
mangé des proches qui sont qui sont
enfermés j'ai des proches de proches qui
sont enfermés voilà la famille les
poteaux et des frères des parfois des
soeurs et on essaie de leur remonter le
moral quand un peu voilà il s'inquiète
souvent de la famille de or justement
pour certains de leurs parents lors
qu'ils sont âgés et qui du coup sont
exposés un strict un certain certains
d'entre vous ont peut-être même déjà
perdu des gens dehors et donc il n'y a
rien de pire que d'être enfermé et de
perdre quelqu'un en fer de ne pas
pouvoir se rendre aux obsèques ni-ni ni
assisté à ces derniers instants ni quoi
que ce soit donc ça va être très très
compliqué à gérer
c'est pour ça que voilà moi je vous
demande juste de rester fort de rester
très très fort il n'y a pas grand chose
de plus à dire c'est juste un message de
force donc grand courage à vous tous et
à vous tous
puis comme on dit en prison c'est dur
sortie c'est du sûr en tout cas espérons
qu'on sortira le plus grand nombre
possible en bonne santé de toute cette
merde voilà on entende on met ensemble
loin des yeux près du coeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'homme que nous allons retrouver
maintenant a passé trois ans à fresnes
en deux fois et une année de prison au
togo et publié un livre qui s'appelle
repenser la prison le mot de la fin
aujourd'hui on le donne à loïk le floch
prigent
bonjour loïk le floch prigent bonjour
vous m'appelez bien belle vous oui oui
oui oui j'aime bien vous êtes loïk le
floch prigent à l'industriel un
serviteur de l'état un grand patron mais
est ce qu'on appelle un col blanc on va
dire en tout cas que la prison n'était
pas une éventualité dans votre vie
est-ce qu'ils sont durs vos souvenirs de
prison absolument mais c'est encore plus
dur de penser combien de gens y sont
toujours sans qu'on leur donne du sens
ch vous écrivez dans votre livre je vous
cite j'ai déjà parlé de la première nuit
elle est souvent la cause de figure
psychologique durable que les mois
suivants ne font qu'approfondir
visiblement on oublie pas c'est vrai et
je continue à ne pas les oublier mais on
va j'essaie de j'essaie de le faire
quand même
et de penser plutôt aux autres qu'à moi
ce qui me frappe moi c'est que tout ce
qui n'avait a priori pas la prison dans
leur champ de vision dans un projet où
possibilité dans leur vie et qui sont
pourtant allés ça leur semble
inconcevable qu'on continue comme ça je
vois bien que vous saisissez ça fait
deux livres que vous écrivez sur les
détentions
c'est quelque chose que vous ne mettez
pas derrière vous c'est devenu presque
un combat oui mais d'un combat qui a key
qui peut être mené dans la mesure où les
gens ont envie de réfléchir mais il ya
des moments où les gens ne veulent plus
réfléchir et considère que une fois
qu'on a mis quelqu'un en prison tout va
bien et qu'on s'est débarrassé du mal
c'est un peu comme celui qui a des amis
qui ont un cancer qui dit j'ai pas les
lois qui érigent les attraper ah oui
c'est un peu ça vous dit que vous avez
appris à vous servir d'un centre et
d'une fourchette c'est tout g j'ai
surtout j'ai surtout appris que le sens
de l'humour d'été en ciel et que la
télévision n'était pas une oeuvre
vraiment délétère et qu'il fallait en
rire
lire et écrire c'est ce que j'ai fait
donc à je me suis moqué de moi même et
de moquer des autres et par ailleurs
j'ai lu et j'ai écrit est-ce que vous
gardé des liens avec des personnes
détenues ou des personnels
pénitentiaires de fresnes
j'ai gardé beaucoup de liens au départ
et j'ai considéré que ça faisait du mal
autant eu qu'à moi de se rappeler ces
moments et que ça faisait beaucoup de
mal à nos familles respectives et par
conséquent j'ai arrêté et je garde
énormément de d'amitié de même de
tendresse pour un certain nombre de
détenus et de gardiens
mais ça ça ne me permettait pas de devis
ou 2 août survivent qu'on veut mais ça
se sent ça gênait les uns et les autres
la prison ça change un homme
oui forcément si fortement
on sait quel que soit l'individu est
d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai été j'ai été
surpris de voir des gens qui étaient
auprès de moi et et qui était considéré
comme nettement plus plus fort que moi
et qui ont été absolument transformer de
fond en comble le fond en cours pour moi
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir une famille
absolument remarquable et je pense que
c'est pas donné à tout le monde et je
remercie ma famille tous les jours
d'avoir existé d'avoir fait ce qu'elle a
fait aussi bien ma mère ma femme des
enfants
et bien je vous salue le floch prigent
scène biraben merci vraiment beaucoup
pouvoir
moi j'ai rien dit un monde où biraben
comme à ce parent est pas biraben comme
pont-aven bon on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à 19h30 sur elle s'était bien
sûr d'ici là il ya les multidiffusions
vous pouvez aussi aller si vous avez
internet
sur youtube il ya une chaîne lcp on se
retrouve donc à nouveau juste vous dire
que bien entendu tous les livres dont on
a parlé seront livrés à la prison de
rennes grâce à un réseau de libre
indépendant sur lequel s'appuie lire
pour en sortir on se retrouve donc est
sûre je me tourne
vendredi à 19h30 pour des cons fine et
qu'on soit dedans ou dehors
[Musique]
babys aux bébés
alors
b
bb ont trouvé
à l'heure
comme ebay
mieux
m
est monté
la table
faux
m
mais
bébé
[Musique]
iv
b
m